tomorrow there will be a new SNP leader
and a new first Minister for Scotland as
well as either Hamza Youssef Kate Forbes
or Ash Regan takes over from Nicholas
sturgeon now the s p is currently in
coalition government with greens but
would they continue to work with a new
leader well the party is co-leader Lorna
Slater joins us now she's live in
Edinburgh for us and thank you very much
for being with us and we are of course
awaiting at the new uh leadership of the
SNP what are you hoping for tomorrow
I mean what I'm hoping is that the
Scottish greens and the Scottish
government can continue to work together
I think that's been a really productive
relationship I think Scotland Scotland
is better for it our environments better
for it bringing those sort of
progressive values concrete things that
make people's lives better our unique
Scottish child payment free bus travel
for everyone 21 and under things like
our nature restoration fund working to
tackle the biodiversity and climate
crisis in Scotland I really hope that
we'll be able to continue working
together and to deliver on these
excellent policies
you see the key question I guess is on
power sharing right because you
currently have a power sharing agreement
with the SMP in Scotland and your
co-leader said that that could come to
an end depending on the policies that
the new leader adopts what are your red
lines here
the Scottish greens joined the Scottish
government on the basis of an agreement
called the Butte house agreement and
that's 50 pages of policy you can see it
online and within there is things like
commitment to gender recognition reform
commitment to tackling the climate
crisis commitment to creating highly
protected Marine areas for example and
we consider that a package of measures
the green serving government on the
basis of that agreement so any new
leader of the SNP must be committed to
that agreement as a whole for us to be
able to continue to work together
one of the key dividing lines obviously
is the gender recognition bill it is
supported by some but not all of the
contenders is that a red line for you if
they pull out of that legislation will
you refuse to enter power sharing with
them
gender recognition reform has been
passed by the Hollywood Parliament it
was supported by members of every party
it was passed by an overwhelming
majority so that that's done it passed
in Scotland where it sits now is that
the UK government have used an
unprecedented uh mechanism called a
section 35 to block something that has
been passed by the Scottish Parliament
so this isn't just a matter of Human
Rights this is also a matter of
protecting Scotland's Devolution and I
cannot imagine any leader of a party
that is pro-scottish independent
accepting the UK government
undermining Scottish democracy in this
way so absolutely I would expect any
leader of any pro-independence party and
in fact anyone who believes in Scottish
Devolution to challenge that
unprecedented and I think undemocratic
use of that section 35 order
I mean the s p could govern without you
as a minority Administration is it
better to keep a seat at your seat at
the table
that is for the members of the I guess
SMP to decide and then for the members
of the Scottish greens to decide that
cooperation agreement I think is
committed to Progressive values it's
committed to tackling that climate and
nature crisis it is committed to a
vision of Scotland that is greener and
fairer and I very much hope that we can
continue to work together to deliver
that Vision because I think it's the
right way forward for the Scottish
people but we shall see what develops
over the next couple of days